please welcome Academy Award nominee
Josh Rowland an Academy Award winner
nominated again this evening Javier
Bardem
awards for adapted screenplay an
original screenplay were given out at
the very first Oscars and they have been
presented every year since there is a
saying that was true then and remains
through today that you know a script is
good when the writers words float
through your mind and goes straight to
your heart
tonight's nominated screenwriters have
made us think made us feel and forever
changed what's impossible between
directions fade in and fade out so for
the 83rd time in Oscar history here are
the nominees for adapted screenplay
Danny Boyle and Simon Beaufoy for 127
hours based on the book between a rock
and a hard place by Aaron Ralston Aaron
Sorkin for the social network based on
the book The Accidental billionaires by
Ben Mezrich
Toy Story 3 screenplay by Michael Arndt
story by John Lasseter Andrew Stanton
Lee Unkrich
based on the previous films Joel Cohen
and Ethan Coen for True Grit based on
the novel by Charles Portis Debra Granik
and Anne Rosellini for Winter's Bone
based on the novel by Daniel Woodrow I'm
the Oscar goes to Aaron Sorkin the
social network
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Aaron Sorkin
you
thank you it's impossible to describe
what it feels like to be handed the same
award that was given to Paddy Chayefsky
35 years ago for another movie with
network in the title his was an original
screenplay this is an adaptation of a
book by Ben Mezrich so I'm accepting
this on his behalf as well there are a
lot of people who've worked hard in my
corner for a long time and it seems like
the right moment to thank them my
assistant Lauren Loman my researcher Ian
rice back my long-suffering press rep
Troy Fillion all the women of prime rich
Heller built an R and E for Che my
agents are Emmanuel and Jason Spitz who
never blow my cover and revealed that I
would happily do this for free and my
mom and dad who made a life for me where
I get to be a part of nights like this I
wrote this movie but David Fincher made
this movie and he did it with an ungodly
artfulness someone this talented has no
business being the nicest guy in the
world but he is and he made the movie of
any screenwriters dreams he had help
from Amy Pascal Michael Linton and
everyone at Sony whose only mandate was
to make it good from Dana Brunetti seon
Chafin Mike DeLuca and America's best
living film producer Scott Rudin and
from Jesse Eisenberg Andrew Garfield
Justin Timberlake Armie Hammer army
hammer again rashida Jones Rooney Mara
and a cast and crew that followed their
leaders example that good enough was
never good enough uh this movie is going
to be a source of pride for me every day
for the rest of my life that is an
unrepeatable gift all I can say is thank
you
Roxy sorc and your father just won the
Academy Award I'm gonna have to insist
on some respect from your guinea pig
thank you very much
you